[Music]
[Applause]
there is just one person just her we
can't sell them out we need them no I
blew it tell me about your divorce my
hands are very cold which I'm actually
happy about they're always clammy have
you ever noticed we're brunch pals we're
pals have you ever know I have very
clammy hands uh no I didn't know that
but you know what doesn't surprise me I
look like a clam you don't seem
hot-blooded I don't know I think that's
nice I'm like oh I'm like a cool
cucumber yeah but I got the I got the
clam here cucumber here inside of a keep
our boy tradition is that would that be
a deal-breaker for you and fellas if he
had clam hands they're not bad now this
is what I would call moderate I gotta
say it's it's it's it's not really it's
not getting the juices flowing Moisture
is drying you up
well I wanted to ask you we were talking
well no we were talking backstage no
foolin and she was like oh I can't make
fun of your outfit because you like it
what is that something you look for in a
fella like a sharp dresser
I'm not I mean we're chums well I like
guys like I feel like there's an
extended adolescence happening right now
like the New York Times it's at this
article of like guys working on their
Coachella outfits right and it's like a
got like 35 year olds and they're
flamingos onesies and like carrying an
old typewriter and like they all think
they're growing beards like they all
think they're Ernest Hemingway
non-functioning cameras yeah by the way
I've Ernest Hemingway was alive he would
beat the [ __ ] out of everyone of these
hipsters artisanal coffee shop and beard
wax store
get doing know how this is gonna eat
these guys are like 38 barely ready for
pet ownership you have a tie you employ
people you're like a real man I like
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]